the right air jorge lopez hope has his
last timeout against the manors only
allowed the one run probably his best
start of the season for the orioles
and how about that one two three and
down goes gonzales that's how you get
the party started two good sinkers down
to get ahead o2 and he does throw the
four seamer to
the old cross seamer we call and he can
ride it up in the zone and this is what
he does o2 just get it just above the
strike zone at 96 so a good start for
jorge lopez martin perez he's the only
red sox starter who doesn't have at
least one win yeah no decision last time
i went five and two thirds against
detroit giving up a couple of earned
runs in that ball game and that's in
there for strike three right at the
bottom of the zone
caught him looking i thought he was
going to go away with him that time
after the inside fastball but no he goes
back down in the zone at 86 miles an
hour to pick up the strikeout so
completely opposite of what we expected
to happen we thought it'd be a change up
away instead down and in orleans come to
bat in the second no score ryan
montcastle to lead it off he is five for
12 in this series a homer and three rbis
hammers that one weighed down deep down
the left field line it's a fair ball
right on cue
ryan modcastle second homer of the
series third on the season and the
orioles take the early lead yeah well
i'd say the rookies heating up all right
that ball
106.5 off the bat
391 feet boy he's starting to feel it
and now 11 straight games at the orioles
of homer second longest active streak in
major league baseball galvez 284 with
four home runs
pounding ball got right through devers
here's a play and got him nicely done by
bogarts as he got the force play on
severino for out number one yeah very
nice by bogots because he had rafael
devas in front of him and of course when
that happens you kind of lose sight of
the baseball it deflected off the glove
it looked like the debris and right into
the glove
of xander bogots who was heading in that
direction had to have to reach to his
left to make a play on the ball and
still was able to get the force at
second base runners at first and second
and bring up rafael devers who struck
out in the second inning insects trying
to build something here
and there's a wild one all the way to
the backstop that'll advance the runners
to first and second he can become
unglued that's happening quickly in this
inning
back to back no not even close
let's fall down around the foot
of devers so two men in scoring position
for raphael
[Music]
swinging a high fly ball that's driving
back hayes a bit but he's under
and will make the catch tagging up jd
martinez and he is in to score
and the red sox will tie this game on a
sac fly by raffy devers his 29th run
batted in so the wild pitch very
important and the red sox in a 1-1 game
you got a guy here who swung the bat
well in the series ben but strikes out a
lot yup does strike out a lot but you
got to get two strikes first and how do
you get the two strikes 2-2 on the way
he got him
big strikeout two down or how about the
pitch
a change up at 88 miles an hour right on
right change up but watch the late
movement down and in i mean that ball
has got probably how much 10 12 inches
of horizontal break moving left to right
and bobby dalback swings just over the
top of it jorge lopez throws his best
change up of the night a ball and two
strikes
and he got him
big strikeout back to back hayes struck
him out on heat
96 miles an hour gonzalez blows through
it back to back strikeouts and the
go-ahead run for the red sox stays at
third what a night for jorge lopez five
and two thirds only three hits the one
run did not walk a batter punched out
five only 71 pitches but a very high
percentage of strikes over two for trey
hit a fly ball to center and bounced out
to short
2-1 hit well
way back in center field way back
out of here
just right at the 4-10 mark
trey mancini puts the orioles back on
top
home run number seven boom boom
seventh home run now that leads the club
110 miles an hour off the bat straight
away center field that's a long one
night back to the bullpen yeah tanner
scott punched out the only battery he
saw lakins had a perfect inning and
there is paul frye and what a year he is
having on that oriole bullpen 15 games
1.35 era 13-inch pitched opponents
hitting just 191 off the left-hander
paul fry
and he gets him
got him with the breaking ball one down
well that's not even fair 3-0 count
fastball fastball to get it back to 3-2
and you throw that really good slider
down and in and dalbeck swings right
over the top of it a good start for paul
fry here in the top of the eighth
down he goes got him looking two down
well paul fry not
working ahead in these first two betters
but finishing strong and there's that
backdoor breaking ball tomorrow and
gonzalez gets his feelings hurt yeah
it's not the way you teach it right bent
down 3-0 and 2-0 and the two hitters he
faced and comes back to strike a boat
that one because it's a ball out of the
hand and as a hitter you give up on it
just
for an instant then it's too late to get
it going again here's alex verdugo head
of verdugo 1-2
bounce to galves
over to first and fry takes care of him
one two three orioles coming to back
bottom half of the eighth inning 2-1
baltimore we start the bottom half of
the eighth inning the orioles have
cedric mullins up first
popped up left side
boguards
whoa juggles it and can't control it
mullins around second heading for third
nobody covers
eventually vasquez gets there but can't
get the tag down what a heads up play by
mullins who never stopped running and
he's at third with nobody down
love love love the hustle by cedric
mullins the ball he probably thought was
going to be caught off the bat but he is
off and running right away you can see
he is moving to shift his own difficult
play there's the juggle and another
bobble and cedric mullins running the
entire time he gets a second base to
realize there is nobody at third and
there's your insurance run sitting at
third base with nobody out so here's
mancini homer just lasted back to give
the orioles the lead
first pitch line drive base hit that'll
get him home
hayes around second he'll hang on right
there and an rbi base hit for trey
mancini ambushed the first pitch right
by the pitcher andres trey mancini
drives in his 29th run of the year hayes
at third mancini at second and severito
down at first freddie galvez trying to
extend that 10-game hit streak
fly ball it should be deep enough to get
in a run hayes tags at third
the throw comes into third and the
orioles get another run give freddy
galvez an rbi austin hayes comes in to
score and the orioles go up 4-1
one strike away from an oriole win and
save number eight for valdez here comes
the o2
got him looking ball game
get some one two three with a couple of
strikeouts
and that one was on the fastball humped
up to 85 miles an hour and just blows it
right past devers looking for that
change up and he's caught looking and
how about this oriole pitching staff
holds the best team in baseball to just
one run
on four hits